oh I'm Brett champion and I'm the
visualization manager here at Wolfram
research and today I'll be talking about
advances in visualization and we'll look
at the newest features and what is
coming in the next version coming soon
good morning welcome my name is Brett
champion I'm the visualization manager
here at Wolfram and today I'm gonna be
talking about advances in visualization
and we'll spend a little bit of time
looking at some of the new features in
12 point Oh and probably a little bit
more than a little bit of time looking
at some of the things that are coming in
the next version so before we get
started I'm going to plug the talks for
the rest of my team members they're all
in this room Emanuel is going to be
speaking about Geographic visualization
immediately following this talk Nirmal
is going to be talking about
complex-valued visualization at one
o'clock after lunch and min is going to
be talking about automated labeling and
visualization at 4:30 and as a
consequence of them having their own
talks I'm not really going to say
anything much about Geographic
visualization or complex-valued
visualization or labeling in this one
which leaves us with a couple major
areas for that were improved in version
12.04 is visualizing uncertainty with
the addition of a round and vector
around and some functionality and
tooling around them and so we'll just
take a look at a few examples and so I
have a few data sets the first one is
just a list of numbers and each of them
has an Associated uncertainty with them
all of these examples that I'm going to
be showing have symmetric uncertainty so
same amount above is below the central
value it's not restricted to that it
works generally with
a non-symmetric forms as well it's a
little bit more complicated visually and
I don't know that it necessarily adds
that much to the presentation so so as
I'm saying we have our first data set
and it just has a list of 15 values each
with some uncertainty uncertainty is
relatively large just so that the people
in the back have some chance of seeing
the error bars and so the support is not
across all 150 visualization phone
functions that we have at the moment for
some of them it doesn't quite make as
much sense and for some of them it
perhaps still make sense but isn't of
the same importance level and so we
didn't so we haven't done them yet
in general with a lot of the features we
sort of rolled them out you know we
start them at the top of the
visualization hill and then they fall
downhill through following versions and
so we have the list plots and bar charts
which are probably 98% of what people
visualize uncertainty with and these
probably look reasonably familiar to
everybody you have points or bars and
then you have the uncertainty
represented by these lines which we'll
get into a little bit more but is we're
calling interval markers as the general
term which allows us to add more forms
of uncertainty down the road without
having locked ourselves in to say error
bars is terminology or something and so
the interval markers we can change how
they look so list line plot at the
moment is still using the
the vertical line segments I can set an
interval markers to bands and then I get
continuous representations of
uncertainty along the curve we can
change the style of the interval markers
so for the list line plot where we have
the this default fences form I've
changed it to black I know that that's
you know perhaps not the most obvious
thing on this projector it's a little
bit clearer on upper you know up close
and on the smaller screen for the bands
I turn them yellow
I actually made them opaque because
otherwise the filling by default is
partially transparent and you have even
less chance of seeing that on this
projector from the back row and so you
have the ability could to control how
the uncertainty is represented and how
it is styled so we also support where it
makes sense
uncertainty on a per dimension basis so
here's X and y values each with their
own uncertainty and there's a couple of
representations that we have for that
the default is using crosshairs which we
see on the left we also have the ability
to represent it as ellipses which by
setting interval markers again on the
right and if you have vector around then
that allows you the way to represent
correlated uncertainty between the x and
y dimensions and so if you look at
vector around you have a point and then
you have a correlation matrix here and I
used mean around to get a bunch of those
from some randomly generated points and
when we look at the ellipsis with those
then they are no longer axis aligned
because of the correlation
so for 12.1 we're adding uncertainty to
a couple of the 3d visualizations in
particular this point plot 3d and list
plot 3d drag that out a little bit
bigger so it's not quite so small next
to its neighbor and in this case the
interval markers will be a little bit
different at least initially we're not
supporting the surface version of bands
in this plot 3d at the moment I don't
think it would necessarily be that
difficult to do but I'm also not sure
that if you have an additional surface
above and below that that you're going
to be able to see that much and make a
meaningful draw a meaningful conclusions
from it and as in 2d you can have per X
or per dimension uncertainty so this is
again so we have uncertainty in x y and
z and you get crosshairs going in every
which direction and so that is where
we're at in broad terms with uncertainty
at the moment for visualization the next
thing I'm going to talk about briefly is
multi panel displays so this is an
ongoing project into how to represent
data in nice-looking grids of graphics
and so this is just a relatively simple
example I have three cities Champaign
Minneapolis Memphis and I grabbed their
temperature data since the start of the
year and normally if I feed this into
date list plots it would give me three
curves there would be different colors
and they would intersect each other and
potentially be kind of noisy
and difficult to read so instead in this
case I'm going to say a plot layout goes
to column and then that is giving me
three separate panels each one with a
curve all three of them have the same
scales on them and what I mean by the
same scales is twofold
so the clearer one is that the x-axis
the January through beginning of
November is the same for all of them so
if you take a vertical slice then
September first is the same vertical
pixel all the way up the slightly more
subtle one is that the Y ranges are the
same on all of them
the ticks look a little bit different
because we're avoiding colliding ticks
at the corners here but zero to twenty
here is the same as zero to twenty here
is the same as zero to twenty there if I
was seven feet tall or had really long
arms and so this is an alternate form an
altered way of presenting your data
again this is available in most of the
list plotting functions at the moment
and in addition to column there's row
there's a grid form where you can say I
want two columns or three columns or two
rows whatever and as I was saying right
now it's supported in 12.0 and most of
the list plot functions let's plot this
line plot log plots dateless plot
obviously the exception that I can think
of off the top of my head is the stacked
list plot which already does its own
thing with multiple data sets and sort
of splitting it out into multiple panels
sort of is counter to its mission
already and then in 12.1 we may pick up
a couple more of his functions that
supports this sort of outputs depending
on how the time shakes out and what
other projects get deemed more important
so okay question is so right and so this
is not using graphics column so graphics
column graphics great graphics row also
have some improvements in 12-point oh I
don't have any examples of them on the
screen right now or in this talk but in
general those functions by default if
you have things like this and so the
issue is traditionally if you did say a
graphics column you and you had zero to
one on this axis and zero to a thousand
on this axis then graphics column would
have each of the graphics the same width
but for this one that went up to a
thousand a little bit more of the text
would be you know there would be more
space on the left-hand side because it
had to represent the effect the thousand
and then this line would you know match
up to like here or something on the
bottom one that should not happen in 12
point O in 12 point Oh graphics column
and graphics row and graphics grid make
sure that the space outside the frame is
the same for all the plots and and so
what it will do is this one will know
that this one went out to a thousand and
had extra space over here so it will add
the same amount of extra space here so
that the frame edges will line up
multiple what I I have ideas on how to
do it and I hope to get there well I'm
sure we'll get there eventually I it's
not gonna happen for 12.1 I'm sure but
it then becomes a question of you know
basically an indexing problem so if I
have two curves per plot how do I
control which two curves how do I
control say plot styling or filling or
this sort of thing so if I have two
curves and I want to fill from one to
the other fill between them that syntax
gets a little bit more complicated so we
aren't there yet but I have ideas on
what the design for that should be
I think that one's just sitting aspect
ratio and it's turning the labels on for
each one
mm-hm
right
and that is in the pipeline but not I'm
not prepared to speak about it today I
mean not only is there code in the
internet there's a version of that in
the function repository okay so moving
on so briefly in so now we're gonna be
looking at forthcoming 12.1 features
region plot 3d will be able to work on
multiple regions which it hasn't been to
do until now I think it was one of the
few exceptions to the working on
multiple forms so here I have three
cylinders plot them all the same time
they all get different colors and as I
say that's a long time coming
contour plot 3d is gaining the ability
to plot over region which most of the
other symbolic visualization functions
have had for a couple versions now and
so here I have some function that I
picked and we're plotting it over the
unit ball and it looks kind of cool and
what you may notice is that in this plot
there are two contours the yellow one in
the and the blue one and then there's
also the actual ball and so this is
being controlled by a new option which
is called region boundary style and I
can turn it off in which case we don't I
get that ball or I can specify that it's
a particular color in this case green
which you know I'm not sure that I would
use green is a default for most things
but hopefully it shows up reasonably
well and what we found is that this is a
useful technique for a lot of these
things that are generating what they
generate is
a subset of the space that they're being
plotted over and so contour plot you
have your space and then you're doing
slices through it and especially when
you have plotting over some arbitrary
region you sort of lose that information
about what the space originally was and
and so we're adding that boundary style
in as a reference for that and that will
then roll out two additional functions
where it's especially useful
okay that's working now if you were you
to stalk on Monday then you saw that we
are adding hatching and other shading
techniques and the hatching I'm
especially excited for for visualization
purposes and so I think there's still
some design work and do exactly what the
syntax for this is going to be and what
the defaults are but I just want to
point out that we can use it as a chart
style we can use it for filling style so
David you're saying you want me to make
it bigger
[Laughter]
okay I have not tried wrapping a dynamic
around it and having the lines but I'm
going to try that and you guys are going
to get the credit but so anyway the
hatching and [ __ ] and the new shaders
should work throughout the visualization
functions in the places where you would
expect them to I mean the points I mean
the points themselves
I don't know that hatching will do
anything with them some of the other
filling in list plot or whatnot it may
come into play whether or not that's
what you actually want I'm not sure
and so now I'm going to spend the last
five minutes going through some
improvements to vector plotting that
we've been working on so how many people
were at Tuesday morning's talk by the
May men's on computational mindfulness a
few people so that inspired me a little
bit for this talk and so part of their
talk was you'll basically spot the
differences between two images and I
thought I would do that with the vector
plots well with one vector plot so the
left hand one is going to be version
twelve the right hand one is the
forthcoming version and what will
there's going to be some differences
they might be a little bit subtle yep
there we go
especially if I only put it on screen
for half a second good
and so there are multiple things that
are going on here some of which might be
subtle
so obviously the vectors are larger by
default in the new design the vectors
all have the same length rather than
being scaled according to their norms
the reason for this is well obvious is
that it was sort of very easy previously
to have big empty spaces and your plots
and when there's empty spaces you don't
see the vector and you know it's small
but you have no idea which direction
it's pointing and so we've gone to
constant size vectors using a color
function to represent the norm so that's
one in two the third which is the subtle
one is that the points are actually laid
out differently
so these are on a rectangular grid it's
like 15 by 15 ish something like that
this is actually on a hexagonal pattern
and that gives us a couple things one it
breaks up the grid and so you get a
little bit less optical illusion and
seeing patterns that necessary aren't
necessarily there the other is that it
actually allows us to use larger vectors
oh well okay larger arrows because
you're able to pack them more tightly
without them intersecting and
overlapping each other so how this is
done we have a new option called vector
scaling it is none by defaults which
means don't scale at all I can set it to
automatic in which case it will go back
to a scaled version
where you have some amounts of
proportional arrow length detector norms
you can do log there's also a square
root version in combination with the
other options the log tends to be not
that different because one of the other
things that we added is vector range
this is similar to plot range except for
the vector norms so this is an extreme
pathological case we're dividing by the
norm cubed and so there's one vector
near zero that has norma fective lee
infinity and everything else previously
got washed out and if we look at oh yeah
that bug okay
that should've been fixed in this build
anyway so if we look at the distribution
of the vector lengths in this plot and I
will come over and read them because
maybe David has a chance in the front
row No okay so this is going from zero
to about one and so that infinite sized
vector in the middle isn't being shown
at all or I mean really it is being
shown it just happens that everything
but basically above one has been clipped
to an automatically determined one and
by setting clipping style I can see that
I can see those vectors in black here if
I set none then we get a hole in the
plot where we clipped similar to what
might happen with plots or plot 3d or
density plots I can specify an explicit
set of norms to use in this case all of
them or a numeric range 0 to 10 in which
case we get fewer black ones in the
middle
and we'll see if that okay vector aspect
ratio which controls the length to width
of the vectors sort of within these
boxes so if I change that to 2/3 from
its default 1/4 ish then I get sort of
thicker vector markers in this case
vector points as I mentioned we have
hexagonal we also have ways of doing non
regular generated vector points which
catches you know curves in some ways a
lot better than any type of regular or
semi regular version does and it's
especially good in the case where you
have a region function or R over non
rectangular domain and and so you I mean
especially this one on the left and I
mean both of these captures the fact
that we're plotting over a disc much
better than this one does which almost
looks like it you know it's just a
square rotated 45 degrees and then again
similar to what we saw with complex plot
contour plot 3d this has region boundary
style and in 2d we also pick up region
filling style which has allows us to
control what the fill color is in 3d the
fill color would just sort of get in the
way and we don't necessarily have a good
way of rendering it right now anyway so
that is two minutes past my time I'm
going to stop and allow Manuel to come
set up his question his computer and
while he's doing that I will answer a
question so thank you
you